みなさん、ここでドガンしました。今日
は、Twitchのプロのストリーマーである友人のレトロ
ガイジンが参加して
います。彼は日本にも住んでいるので、過去のビデオで彼と一緒にビデオを作りたかったのです。
日本ですべての代替作業を行う
ことは、日本のyoutuberであるクリエイティブな作業のよう
なものです
が、
ライブストリーミングのストリーミング
、より具体的には、けいれんや
ゲームストリーミングの詳細については、これまで詳しく説明し
ていません。 それは私の専門分野ではありません
が、
それはレトロの専門分野なので
、おそらく1時間半ほどかかり
、彼からできる限り多くのことを学ぼうと思ったので、
これを見ている人がいるかもしれません。 今高校生
です多分あなたは今大学生で
日本に引っ越したいと思ってい
ますストリーミングに興味があるなら時間とエネルギーを節約できるかもしれませ
ん
この全体を通してレトロ私たちは匿名性について話していなかったとは思いませんし
、あなたの
本名やものが好きなので、それ
はクールですそれは大丈夫ですドーガン大丈夫大丈夫
私たちは大丈夫です
ベーシックええと自己紹介
ええええと私はレトロな男です私は日本のライブストリーマーです私は
これを約
5、6年やっています
ええと私は住んでいました私は日本に住んでいます
6、7年、私は現在
沖縄に
住んでいます。私は生計を立てるためにビデオゲームをプレイし
ています。また、時々外に出て
、
日本のようにライブストリーミングを行って、
東京のような人々や
彼らが望む楽しい場所を紹介します。 わかりました。
申し訳ありませんが、私は31歳です。3歳です
。
これまで話したことはないと思います。
あなたのバックストーリーのようなものを手に入れるために、
そして私たちはそこから一種のビルドを
する
ので、あなたはいつも日本に興味を持っていました
なぜあなたはe 日本では、大学時代
に何をしたいのかわからなかったのです
が、多くの人の
ように、心理学専攻のよう
なものだったと思い
ます。
そうですね、心理学専攻の一環として外国語を勉強し
なければなりませんでした。ビデオゲームが
好きで、
ポケモンとドラゴンボールが好きだったので、ランダムに日本語を勉強
しました。 日本から勉強を始めたの
ですが、これが
私が勉強したい唯一のことだとわかりまし
た。大学を楽しんだのと同じように、実際に大学を楽しんだ
ので、勉強を続け、
最終的に専攻をええと変えました。 アジアの
研究
は私の最後の専攻でし
た。大学で私はnagoya
と
uhhiroshimaとkyotoのように1か月の
海外旅行のように旅行したことを覚えています。
家族
と私が sそこに私はこのようでしたこれは
この場所がちょうど1か月とても涼しいのでこれは素晴らしい
です
そして私は恋に落ちました私は私が
最終的にここに戻って来なければならないよう
でした tqlと呼ばれる会社
は、まるでトラックのように冷静に
電話をかけ
ているようなもので、貨物ブローカーのようなものです。
嫌いな男ii
は、これまでで最悪のことでした。
私は、apuでの私の古い仕事とまったく同じ方法でした。私は、
それが嫌いでした。
ええ、その8か月後
、私は給料を削減することを知っているよう
でした。私はただ幸せではない
ので、その後、オハイオ州シンシナティで少し待っているようなもの
でした。
ええと、テーブルを待っている間、私は
あなたがその日本のものがクールだったことを知っているようでした
卒業してから1年か2年くらい
だと思いますので、発砲し始めました。ウェブサイトgaijinpot.comを使用しています。そうですね、gaijinpotを使用しました。
さまざまな
アプリケーションすべてのこれらの会社私は
5つの異なるインタビューのように私は次々とシャットダウンされて
いたのを覚えてい
ますそれはすごいダン
ええとのようなもの
でした
彼らに参加するの
は間違っていませんああ大丈夫大丈夫だから彼らは
すべて
英会話教室のスカイプインタビューです
私はそれを送るつもりなら何でもそうだったのを鮮明に覚えて
いますそして私は隣のバーに行ったようでした
私は
巨大なビールの
ようでした。私はこのインタビュー
を2時間ほどで受けたと知っていましたが
、これまでのところすべてが束ねられていたので、背の高いグラスのビールを持っていたのを覚えています。
どんなパンツを着ていても
それは私が彼らが私を雇った仕事の男を得た
ものでしたそれはとても面白かったので彼らは
あなたを日本の
どこ
に置いたのですか 私は
あなたが鎌川
千葉に行くようなもので、私は今はどうなっているの
か気にしないので、そこから
私が理解し
た
ので、彼らは私を鴨川千葉に入れました そして、私
は1年間東京に引っ越す前に、約4年間神川に滞在することに
なりました。それから、今は約1
年半
大丈夫
です。  「あなたはツイッチでライブストリーミングビデオゲームをしていますか？
ビデオゲームは常に
あなたの人生の主要な部分でしたか？
ええ、私はあなたが見たいゼルダのタトゥーを手に入れました
私はゲームをプレイしたのと同じようにゲームが好きです私の人生
は時間のオカリナのようにおそらく私の
お気に入りです oriteゲームとWarcraftの
世界のようにプレイ
し、ここで大きなゲーマーが育っているので
、私のチャンネルの多くの人がこれを知っていると思いました。
高校の終わり、それから私
は本当に
武術のトリックの
ようになり始め、大学では日本人のようなものになりましたが
、私は武術の
トリックに夢中になっ
ていて、トリッキーな人は誰もが
自分のビデオをアップロードする場所を必要としていたので、
私は知っていました youtubeと私は
youtubeが出てすぐにyoutubeにアップロードし始めました
が、私はけいれんについて本当に知りませんでした
、そして人々はそれでお金を稼ぐような
ものでした、あるいはそれが一種の確立された後かなりまでそれが何であったかさえ
それで、あなたは最初からけいれんをしていましたか、いや
、
私は同じようでしたええと、
私は
けいれんについて何も知らなかったのですが、ほとんどの人がやっていることではありません
お気に入りのTwitchストリーマー
を見るのが好きな人の多くは、男性対ゲームのようなこの人のようなものです。
彼はTwitch uhライブストリーミングのogの一人だったので、多くの人にストリーミングしてキャリアを開始するように促したので、本当に良い例です。
そして、多くのogs
はまだええと周りにあります
が、私はけいれんについて何も知りませんでした
、そして私は私がけいれんを始めた方法のように入ることができる
と思い
ます
ええと、
明らかにあなたのような愚かなことは、世界が
今非常に不安定な状況にあり
、多くの人々が切望していることを知っています。このため、多くの人々は
、いわば通常の仕事の安定性に疑問を
投げかけています。 多くの人が
この次のセグメントから
、あなたがどのようにしてそれに参加し、成長し始めたかについて学ぶことができます
ええ、それはそのようなショットであるため、
人々に伝えるのが好きである
か、Twitchでストリーミングを開始することをお勧めするのが常に難しいかどうかはわかりません
暗い男リック
ええと、インターネットで成功
するのは、99のようなものです。私たちはあなたと私のようにとても幸運な男です。私たちはとても幸運です。
どこにでも行って、
まるで運のようです。たくさんの運が面白いと思います。
私は別の哲学から来
ました。友人がいました。この男はアンドリューという名前で、
彼も日本に住んでいて、日本で働いています。
そして、私は
youtube um youtuberをやってい
たのですが、彼が私に言ったことの1つは
、あなたが一生懸命働いてそれを維持
すれば、あなたが成功するかどうかは問題ではないということ
です。 あなたは成功する
ので、iii
は、時間と労力を
費やすと、私のもう1人の
juji mufuがインスタグラムに誰がいるのか知っていますか？
スプリットと椅子のように、
とにかく彼はええと、その男は大丈夫です 彼
はかつてはトリックスターだったので、
私がやっていることをやったのです
が、彼が言っていたことの1つで
あり、彼が勧めたのは
、どんな分野でも成功するための鍵
です。
あなたも
有能であるため、彼は彼が
本当にトレーニングが得意であることを知って
いたので、基本
的に私はそれがあまり得意ではなかったので、私はそれをあきらめなければなりませんでした、
そして私は怪我をしました、そして
彼女はマガリマです
さて、トリックは
基本的に
は、
武道の体操のブレイクダンス
とアクロバットの組み合わせ
です。この形で人々と戦うの
は、床のような
体操の要素の
ようなものです。 フィールドか
何か、そしてただあらゆる
種類の楽しいフリップをするハァックールな音
素晴らしいええええええ
とにかく私はそれが好きでしたええと私はそれで
ちょっと
大丈夫でしたが私はそれから
お金を稼ぐことができないだろうということをかなり早く学び
ました 私はそうではありませんでした
私はそれを本当に上手くする可能性がありませんでした
ええそれ
は
私が敗北者のようになりたくないという
本当にええと前向きな哲学の
ようなものです あなたがそれをするだけなら、それ
はええと、右、右の問題ではないことを知っている
ので、
人々
がけいれんでそのルートを試してみるのを見ただけで、
私はたくさんの壊れた心を見てきました
けいれんは面白い獣なので、人々からの興味深い失望は、
あなたが医者の軽蔑のようなものでない限り、一晩でウイルスに感染するのが好きではないようなYouTubeではありませ
ん。
あなたはゲーマーを知っています
それは飽和状態です私は
あなたがあなた自身のニッチを見つけるのが好きでなければならないのであなたをユニークにするもののようです
まあ
、けいれん右の大きなことです
ええと、ええ、ええ、ええ、ええ、
ええ、確かにそこに戻りましょう。
私は鴨川
千葉にいて、当時のガールフレンドは
2週間ほどカナダに行って、とても
退屈していました。
大乱闘スマッシュブラザーズ
が出てきたのは何だったの
かわからなかったので、大乱闘スマッシュ
ブラザーズが
日本で3dsに出てきたのはご存知でしょう。
最新の
大乱闘スマッシュブラザーズゲームのデモ
は 日本の早い段階で
、このデモをダウンロードするには日本の3dsが必要だった
ので、
海外の人やここにいない人
はアクセスできませんでし
た。私と私はスマッシュが大好きです。
多分いくつかのyoutubeのことをやっていて
、私は退屈して
いて、何もしなかった2週間のようでした。
この
デモが出てきたのを知って
いるようでした。これを世界に放送したり、
人々に
見せたりするための私のオプションは何ですか。 それに
あなたが望んでいた
ただプレイするのではなく、
人々
に見せるために
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 私は
twitchというウェブサイトのようなものを探し回っ
て
います。彼らはリーグオブレジェンドトーナメントのようなものだと聞いたと思い
ますが、このウェブサイトについては何も知りませんが、アカウントを作成します。
ええと、私はそれをストリーミングします私はちょうど
このカメラを指さし
ました私は今私がちょうど
くだらない私のラップトップカメラを持っていますそれは
私のラップトップに差し込まれたように私のラップトップをひっくり返し
そして後ろから抱き締めて
それを置きました
3dsと私は
、ラップトップを後ろから抱き締めてライブで
演奏し
ます。あなたが今言っていることがわかります。
そうでない人には視聴者が多すぎます
ストリーム右mm-うーん
男それは大丈夫のようでしたええ
私のようにスマッシュを愛する人々それはああ私の神のようです
それは最新のゲーム
です
それは最初に3dsで出てくるようにそれを最初に見た
ええええそれはそうですそして私は遊んでいます
そして私はそれがどのように感じるか
とこれらすべてのものについて話します
そして私はそれを1日か2
日3日ほどしましたそして私は私の最初の40の寄付のようになったのを覚えています
そして私は大喜びしました それは
私の心を吹き飛ばし
ました私は私がビデオゲームをプレイしてお金を稼いだ瞬間を決して忘れ
ません
ええ、
私はここで英語の先生をしていました。
ここに何かある
ので、これを試してみるかもしれません。
父に
もっと良いマイクのように買えるかどうか尋ねたところ、
彼はそう言ったので、許可してくれました。
彼のクレジットカードを
使ってアマゾンからマイクを買うのが好き
です。 その時点で自分の日本のクレジットカードを持っているのは、あの日本
の新しい外人のように、
どこにも行かない
ので、私は投資し
て、常連客が戻ってくるような毎日のようにゆっくりとそれを構築し始めました。
初めて写真を撮ったときは100人の視聴者の
ようにヒットした
ことを
覚えて
おいてください。100人の人の
ようにすごいです。 少しの間、
それは最終的にwii uで出てきて
、ストリーミングするためにエルガトを購入しました。そこ
からエルガトも入手したと思います。
私の
友達は別のキャプチャ方法を見つけたの
ですが、エルガトを手に入れるまでは
、外部カメラ
を使用してそれをテレビやラップトップに向けていましたか、
それまでどのようにキャプチャしていましたか？
ビルトインのcだけでした 私のラップトップでアメラを使っているので、あなた
はそれを何ヶ月もやり
続けました
私
はここで手首のような保護具を着用するの
が好きでした。なぜなら、
私がストリーミングのようにファンが私の腕を
燃やすような
ものだったからです。
m
ストリームを200
人、時には300人で終了し、
ホストする人がいないので、ウェブサイトに友達がいなかった
ので、周りを見回したい
と思いました。彼の名前を見つけた最初のストリーマー
は タイガーライターで
あり、彼は私
が彼をフォローしたばかりのように今日まで私の友人であり、彼は一種
の新進のストリーマーでもあり、彼の雰囲気が本当に好きでし
た。
彼はアラスカの野蛮人という名前の別の男を紹介してくれ
ました。 ええと花婿付け添人としてのtwitchconでのアラスカの野蛮人の結婚式
結婚式のように、
タイガーライダーが結婚式を担当している
ように、彼
は右前の男のようです。それは
素晴らしい話です。
それはクレイジーです。これ
はけいれんのために起こったようで、
私たちが最初に作ったつながりの
ようです。
とてもかっこいいですすごい
面白いので
、あなたが今この場所にいる理由の1つは、
このフルタイムでできる場所にいるように感じます。これは
、良いスタートを切ったからです。
そのゲーム
の勢いで、確かに正確な絶対的な男であり
、スマッシュの誇大宣伝が本当に良かったことを知っていたので、
私は途中でいくつかのスマートな動きをしたと思います
大乱闘スマッシュブラザーズを
挽くだけですが、ビッグボーイが争いに巻き込まれたら、
メタのような競争力のあるものが
設定されたので、ハングアップできず
、ある時点でプロの人々のようにスマッシュで本当に良い選手がいることを知っていました
生計を立てるためにそれを行う人
は、ひきつりしてストリーミングを開始
します。それから、視聴者リストをノックダウンすることを
知っ
てもらいます。
人々がディレクトリに行くとき、あなたよりも視聴者数がトップに近い
ので、それが来ることを知っていたので、
準備しました
。これをバラエティゲームのようにやってみようと思った
ので、毎週月曜日のようにレトロのように
月曜日と私の名前はレトロガイジンなので、私
は
そういうものにぴったりだったので、毎週月曜日
は古いスーパーニンテンドーゲームのように遊んで
、スマッシュ以外のさまざまなコンテンツに人々を慣れさせるために
私もやりました いくつ
かのええとh1z1バトルロワイヤル
大丈夫これはbrシーンの早い段階のようなものです
ええと私はある日
スマッシュ1日h1z1ある日スマッシュ1から
h1z1に切り替えてからレトロな月曜日のよう
に コミュニティ
はい ええ、スマート私が本当にやりたかったことの1つは、
人々に来てもらいたいということでし
た。キャラクターのレトロな外人は、ちょうど
右にスマッシュするだけで
はあり
ません。 私はそれがあなたのアバターだということを意味します
ええええ私はそのヘッドバンドのように着ていまし
た日本のヘッドバンドは
それが日本の日本と言っているものは何でもミートボールのように言い
ます
黒と赤のように
それは私のものでした、そして私は
2年のようにすべてのストリームを着るでしょう
そして人々はまだ
私がドレープしたい超長いヒッピーの髪のようにヘッドバンドを元に戻すように言います
ええと、それはかなり
コミカル
で、あなたが知っているかなりユニークなようだった
ので、私はちょっとそれと一緒に行きまし
た のような e dojo rightだから
、私たちは私の
ブロジョでたむろして、ただたむろし
て話をしました。私はこれらすべての
アートとこれらすべてのグラフィックとものが
好きでした。私はレトロニーと呼ばれるキャラクターを作りました。
大丈夫な
ので時々私はこれをこのように着て
話したり、私の声のように声を変えたり、
広告
のようにしたりし
ます私がやろうとしていたこと
は誰かが私に気づいたようだったと思うので
このウェブサイトで、
私がこのクレイジーなことをすべてやっていることに気づいてください。
ええと、レトロニーの治世と呼ばれるイントロビデオ
を作りました。
このロチョーニマスクのようになって、
ここに送られたように、地図を
見つけたのですが、タブレットを見つけて読ん
だところ、彼
を目覚めさせたようで、レトロな外人に変身したので
、普通の人のようでした。 それから私
はタブレットを読んで、気絶したように
それから私はヘッドバンドのように目が覚めました
私はああこれは
かなり歯ごたえがあります私はそれがセキロの話だと確信
し
ています
ここでのインスピレーションです
が、大丈夫です。フューチャーマンの
ゲームも彼は別のストリーマーです。
私は彼から完全にそれを取り除くことはほとんど好きではありません
でしたが、彼が彼自身のキャラクターを作ったので、私はそのビデオに非常に触発されまし
た。
バラエティに富んだゲームを手に入れるためにそれをする必要がある
ので、私は自分の
ストーリーを作る必要があるので
、それを少し使ってみましたが
、数か月後に消えてしまった
ので、これを維持することはできません
ばかげていますが、続けて
ください。
少し前に戻って、途中でいくつかのマイルストーン
についてお
聞きしたいと思います。 かなり未来に行くようなもの
です
ええと、最初は
大乱闘スマッシュブラザーズのゲームをストリーミングしていて
、
私たちは毎日ストリーミングをやっていたと言ってい
ました。
最初は
私はたくさんのエネルギーを持っていたと思います。
ほぼ毎日だったと思いますええと
、これを聞いて大きくなるのが好きな場合は、Twitchでストリーミングする
か、何
か良いヒントがあれば、スケジュールを開始し
てください。
スケジュールを
立てるには、この日のようになります。
日本の時間の午後4時のように、
毎日ストリーミングを行って
から、英語の仕事を1、2日休んで、
すぐにあなたの場所に戻って、
基本的にはそうです。 目を覚ますだろ
うええと、私はその時点でパートタイムの英語の仕事が好きだったと教えました
大丈夫私は
もうアカイをしていませんでした私は
地元の学校で働いてい
ました 私の自転車に乗るのと同じように
英語を教えます 8時から正午までshしてから
、自転車に乗ってビーチに行き、波があるかどうかを確認してから、
サーフィンに行ってから戻ってきて
、4時にストリームを開始します。
とても気に入りました。
ええと
、
最初の40ドルは
寄付や
サブスクリプションを受け取り続けました
か
？毎日ストリーミングを続けているので、かなり高い頻度で発生し
続けました。
方法がわかりません。 長い間、そうそう
、彼らはかなり頻繁に来始めました。
なぜなら、人々はコンテンツを楽しんでいて、
私がそれを続けてみたいと本当に望んでいたから
です。
私たちは
あなたがフルタイムで行くのを手伝ってくれるようにサポートする
つもりですので、Twitchの
サブスクリプションと寄付からの
収入はかなり早くあなたの英語の教育収入を上回りました
ええ私はそれが1年のようにかかったと思います
または2つは
大丈夫ですが、私は実際には1日
4時間の英語を教えるほど多くのお金を稼いで
い
ませんでした。
正直に
言うと、お金は気にしないでください。すべてのお金
が私のアメリカのペイパルに送られているように
、お金を見たことがない
ように、ちょうどそこに座っていて
、アメリカで貯金を始めたのと同じように
、 私の
1日4時間の給料の教えは、
おもしろいです。キャプチャカードの購入について
おっしゃっていました。その購入をしたとき
、Twitchを実行可能な仕事として使用することも考え
ていて、将来性があることを確信していると思い
ます。 これ
で、重要な種類のいくつかは何
だと思いますか？より大きな質問は、
どの時点で、
私はもう
通常の仕事をしていない
と判断しましたか？
これを
実現さ
せる 幸い
なことに、ビザが必要だったので、ストリーミングをし
ている間ずっと英語を教え
ていた
ので、1年ほど経った後、あなたは
すでに
ツイッチでより多くのお金を稼いでいましたが、基本的に
教え続けました ビザを維持するためだけに英語
ええ
おもしろいですそしてあなたはそれを
3年か4年の間
やりました そこにビザ
がありますええとあなたの時間はどうでした
かあなたは基本的に
週に5回のようにパートタイムを続けましたか8
から12
はいええ私はパートタイムのルートに行こうとしましたえ
えと
確かに あなたはそれを見つけることができます
ええ時々彼らはちょうど
パートタイムのalt8から正午のように必要です
ええとあなたは知っていますが私は
私のけいれん収入が
私のお金を完全に上回っていた
ので私はちょっとイライラしていました
仕事私は少し憤慨し始めました
ああそうそう私はなぜここにいるのか私は今あなたが知っているけいれんに完全に
集中することができたときに私の時間を無駄にしているのです
視聴者は千五百人くらい
ですが、起きて電車に乗って英語を教えなければならない
ので、寝なければなり
ません。  4、5年以内に試してみてください。
明らかに最後に起こったのは
、あなたが今いる場所にいるからです。
これ
については少し後で説明しますが、4、5年の間に何度も試してみましたか？
ビザを変更するか、友達を通してスポンサーのように
なりましょう。少しだけ話してください。
ええ、ええと、私が調べたものは、
私がけいれんするように手を差し伸べたように、正直に言うのは不可能に思えたから
です。
Twitchjapanrのように日本でストリーミングするビザ
アマゾンが
数年前にそれらを買収したとき、私は
大丈夫だったので、
アマゾンがあなたを所有し
、彼らが世界を所有しているように言い訳はできませ
ん。
彼らが私のためにビザを後援することは不可能のよう
です
が、私は本当にしばらくの間それを振り回そう
としました 不可能のように、
ええ、私は英語を教えていました
ええとパートタイムええ時々フルタイム
パートタイムで5年間フルタイムでストリーミングし
ているのは
面白いです私は反対のこと
をしていました
私は日本の大学でフルタイムで働いていました-
当時、私はYouTubeチャンネルをパートタイムで構築していましたが、
実際には両方の種類
のオンラインジョブを実際のジョブにしたと思います。私が行ったの
とほぼ同じ時期に
、メインのジョブを
約1年半前に辞めました。
ええええええと
言います 同じ大丈夫
ええと、あなたはけいれん以外の誰かに手を差し伸べようとしましたか
？私は
東京の周りの弁護士や何かに手を差し伸べて
、それについて彼らに話したいと思ったかもしれません、そして彼らは
私たち
があなたが何であるかわからないようです 何をしているのかけいれん
何を話して
いるのか何を話しているのか知っ
ているのはYouTubeのようなものです
が、YouTubeのようです
が、日本はこれらのことに追いつくのが少し遅いと思います
ここ数年、e
スポーツビザのようなものがあっ
たり、面白いものがあったりして、少し良くなったと聞きました。これからお話しした
ことの1つは、
東京に友達がいるということです。 娘が生まれてから東京に行け
なかったので、実際に会ったこと
はありません
が、
コナーとギグック、そして明らかに
アニメの男を知っています
が、コナーとギグクはどちらも同じ
ように日本に来た
と思います 彼らはスポンサーを得ました edby私
は
クリエイティブエージェンシーのように信じていますええと多分東京
クリエイティブ
それはそうだと思いますええええ私は
東京
クリエイティブにいます私は彼らがいるのは東京クリエイティブではないと
思います私はそれが別の会社だったと思い
ます 私
がビデオのこの部分のためにええと作りたいのは、
おそらく一年かそこら前
まで、確立された仕事のようなものではなかった分野でええとからビザを取得することは非常に困難だったということです
しかし、現時点では
、東京のクリエイティブと広告
代理店のように見えますが、広告代理店ではなく
、少なくとも
2つの
代理店があります。 ユーチューブ
やツイッチを知っているかどうか、あるいは
彼ら
があなたの影響力の一部と引き換えにビザを提供するかもしれないことは何でも成功し
ます
あなたのマネージャー
や何かのようにあなたの収入のパーセンテージ ええええええそうですそして私は
彼らが東京クリエイティブがしていることの一つは彼ら
がフォロワーを知っている多くの人々と宣伝し
たいような会社との中間的な役割を果たしていると思います
私は再びオイタに出
て、娘が生まれてから東京に行ったこと
がありませんが、東京のクリエイティブの他の多くの人々がスポンサー付きコンテンツのようになることを知っています。
私がまだ東京にいたときに会社を始める前のように私がいたときのことを覚えています私はCEOに会ったことを覚えています
私たちはこれについて話し
ました彼らは
いやのようでしたそして私はそうだとは思わなかった
ので私も東京のクリエイティブに入ろうとし
ましたそして彼らは
彼らがヤダと言ったと彼らは言っ
た それは大丈夫ですそれは
完全に大丈夫です
ええと物事が終わったので
関係なく私のために働いていますが、
それは私が降りようとした道の1つでした
大丈夫トククリエイティブに参加しましょうええ
今彼らは
あなたがeスポーツビザがあると言って
いました
誰かから聞いたことがあるような気
がしますが、
私はそれを作り上げていないのかもしれません。多分
それは都市の伝説
か何かかもしれません。
あなたがあなたの会社を作ったと言ったので、
英語を教えるのをやめ
て、今やって
いることがフルタイムのけいれんを始めた方法について簡単
に話すことができるかもしれません。
まるでクランチタイムのようでした。
英語のビザがなくなり、
今は英語を教えていない
ので、戻って英語のけいれんを教えたくないようなものを見つける必要があります。これ
は絶対に私のフルタイムです。
この時点での仕事は約5年
のgrindiです この時点に到達するために私は
英語を教えるために戻っていないようです
大丈夫私はあなたを本当に早く止めさせてくださいええと
私はただ一つのことを確認したい
あなたはあなたの英語の契約を終えました
そしてあなたは数ヶ月残っていました
あなたのビザは
そうだねええええええええええええええ私は
私が仕事を辞めたと思いましたそして
それからまだここにいまし
た 私は
まだここ
にいて、ビジネスマネージャービザを持っていますが、ビジネスマネージャービザ
まで
は英語教育ビザを持っていましたが、英語を教えて
いませんでした。
ええと
、あなたのビザはおそらく教育のようなものだったと思います
ええええそれは決して期限切れにならなかったので私は
私のビザを超過したことはありませんええええ
それは私の
理解
です ビザを超過しないので
、彼らはただ支出します
自分の面倒を見てください
それはまさに起こったことです私は
東京で英語の教育の仕事をしていました
そして私はそれを再び嫌いでした私はこれが終わったようでした
これは
東京で教えて
いる
ようなものです 獣人それは
本当に寒い
ようでした
いつも
すごかっ
たですええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 沖和
にそしてそれから大丈夫のように私は
このビザに3ヶ月残っている
ように私は私の選択肢は何です
かここで何をするつもりですか私は何
をするつもりですか
そして
あなたは 関係ではなく
、特に沖和で就労ビザを作成する機会があると思ったからではあり
ません。
それは正しいです。
そうそう、絶対に正しい
です。
これは私たちにとって素晴らしい未来だとあなたが知っていると仮定しますええええ
私たちはフルタイムでけいれんをします
おきなわに
ひどく終わって、
それから私は大丈夫のようでした私はきなわに一人でここにいます
私のビザは
3ヶ月のように切れています私の英語のビザは何をする
つもりですか
そしてそれは私が大丈夫のような決定をしたときでした
ここで大きな男の子が遊ぶように、
私たちに何ができるか見てみましょう
沖縄に行ったのは、弁護士のように、また会社を設立できる
ようなものがあることを知っていたからだと思っ
ていたのですが、引っ越してから捜索をし
ました。
そして、私は
何も計画していません男は
私の人生で何かが計画されている
ように行動しません大丈夫のよう
に私はある経験から次の経験につまずくのが
好き
です
子供ができるまで待っ
てくださいええと、それは毎日
ええと、ええ、それはとても楽しいですええ、それは
別の
トピックですなぜ
あなたはええとあなたがあなたの会社を作ったのかについて話してみませんか
私が入ることができるビジネスのものがあるかどうかを確認するために
、私はここでいくつかの地元の人に会いました、そして私たちは
大丈夫のように話し
てい
ました または何かと
どういうわけかビザ
は何も固執していませんでした、そして私は
マイクという名前の沖縄でこの男に会いました、そして
マイクマイクがここに会社を所有してい
て彼は外国人
である
ために私を紹介しました あなた
を
この男に紹介し、彼が私に紹介したの
は税務ビザの男
です。彼は実際の名前のようになっています
が、私は彼を税務ビザの男と呼んで
います。
彼は完全
に彼は完全に合法です彼はあなたが会社を始めるつもりならあなたがそうするのと同じように
あなたはちょうどこれだけのお金を持ってき
てそれを会社に入れる必要があります
スタッフ
と私はすべての事務処理を担当し
、それ以降、あなたは私に
1か月分の収入を支払って、所得税を管理し
ます。 あなたは彼にこれだけのmを与えます oneyと彼
はあなたの名前で会社を作り、
その会社で
あなたのビザ
をあなたが正しいものに変えるのに十分
ですあなたのビザの状態は
それがビジネスマネジャーが大丈夫だと言っているようなもの
です あなた自身のチャンネルそうそうそう
iiは彼に私の状況を説明しましたそして彼
は
あなたが会社を立ち上げるためにこれだけのお金を持ってきて
そしてそれから私に
これを何でも払うならそう
です
あなたから私はこれらすべての書類が必要です
うん、あなたと一緒にビザ事務所に行かせて
ください
そして彼は私をビザ事務所に連れて行きましたそして
私たちはすべてのものを記入しています
そしてそれから1、2ヶ月後に彼
は私をクリスのように呼んでいます
すべてが通過したようにすべてが良いです
そしてあなたのビザは
すぐにそれを拾いに来るようなものですここ
にあなたの会社のあなたのスタンプがあります私は私の小さな会社のスタンプとものをすべて手に入れました
これは素晴らしいと思います
それ以来  確かに、私は
ついにフルタイムでストリーミングでき
、コンテンツの作成に100 uhを入れることができるので、または
あなたが人生で経験している
ものと同じように、ビザのことを心配する必要は
もうありません。
5〜6年間は悪夢のようでした。
ビザをどのように扱っているのか見ている人のように、それは
まるで悪夢の
ようです。最初は理解する必要があり
ます。おそらく
途中でつまずくでしょ
う。  100の正解のようなものがあり
ますええ
私がそれを与えるために使用したデフォルトの答えの種類は
それ
がジェットプログラムで日本に来る
か英語などを教えるために何度も変更されましたそしてそこからええと
その後通常になります 日本の会社なので、これは
以前のyoutubeのようで
、通常の会社が
自分自身を正しく養う唯一の方法だったので、これらすべてのオプションが可能でし
たが、それ以来、日本に行くように変更されました。
eジェットプログラムですが、交換留学生として、
あなた
がビジネスなどを所有し
ていて、あなたが
彼らのビジネスの従業員であり、
おそらくあなたであるように彼らにサインオフさせるような、あなたのコミュニティで影響力のある人に会ってみてください 彼らのために何かをやり直します
が、あなたはそれがあなたが
あなたのためにそのことを喜んでする理由である関係の
ようなものであることを知っています。
約1年
の間にジェットプログラムをやめて日本を
出てから戻ってきて
英語を教えて
いたのですが、週に2回、
毎回3時間くらい住んでいました。
私の貯金からです
が、この間ずっと、私は基本的に
youtubeを作って何かを作ろうと努力し
ていまし
たが、お金が足りなくなっ
て妻に会い、結婚したかったので、最終的には
apuでの仕事に変わりました。 適切なように必要 仕事と
ユーチューブは
それをカットしていなかったか、まだカットをして
いなかった
ので、それは私が
2番目に勧めたものでしたが、今
私がお勧め
するのは
、成功
し、有能で影響力のある
ものになる前に話したことです
あなたが使用したい用語は
、私たちが再び話していることが
けいれんやユーチューブのような
ものであるか、ある種のオンラインの努力が
おそらくそれを説明するための最良の方法で
あり、それからちょうど代理店か何かのようになることを知っているなら、この特定のことで上手になります
スポンサーに
なるのは良い
アドバイスですが、YouTubeチャンネルを
視聴している人の数
や、インターネットで
影響力のある人のように知っている人のように、多くの人にとっては到達できないと思います。
ある人がこれをよく見ている
ので、私は
これを作るつもりだという考え方でYouTubeに入ったので、これが実際に面白いと思うかもしれません。
ええ、あなたと一緒にあなた
がけいれんを始めたように聞こえます、そしてあなたは成長に驚いていました、そしてそれはあなたが
それを続けた理由です、しかし
あなたが
最初にそれを始めたときあなたはそれをあなたの完全にしようとしていませんでした
-
時間の仕事か、私がちょうど
いじっていたものは何でも私は思った、そして
あなた
が
私がそれに入るのは本当に悪い考え方であるたくさんのお金を稼ぐつもりであるという考え方で入るなら、それはコンテンツ作成
に入ると思う
そうそうそうそう私はお金について話しているのではなく
、いわばお金についてもっと話しているの
は確かに1つの要素ですが、
私は
成功し、このように有能になるでしょう
それは素晴らしいことです
まだ持っている良い考え方
とあなたは成功のあなた自身の定義が人から人へと変わることを知っています
多分彼らはただカップルの
視聴者
を望んでいます
収入
右右右ri  ght今
、
私はそうそうできるところにいますが、最初はそれ
は間違いなくプールではなく、
多分後に私が思うけいれんのこと
を通してビザを取得する情熱のようなものでもありませんでした
それをやって1年か2年のように私は大丈夫のようでした
今私は私の英語の仕事よりも多くのお金を稼いでいます
それは最初のポイントではありませんでした
私はただ成長
してけいれんの誰かになりたいと思っていました
インターネットシーンの誰かになりましょう。
多くの人が始めたばかりのときは
、自分のコンテンツを評価して
もらいたいと思っているだけです。それは良い出発点
だと思います。
確か
に私の中には潜在意識のあるドガンが2人いるようなものがあったと思います
。1人は
作家
になり、小説家になり、
これをフルタイムでやりたいと思ってい
ます。 私の肩に小さな悪魔のドーガンのようです
が、 うまくいかなかっ
たので
、本を売ろうとする代わりに
、YouTubeで書いたこれらのスクリプトを実行できます。
おそらくそれを実現でき、
フルタイムで実現したいのです
が、他の もう一人の
犬は、あなたが言っ
たことのように、あなたがそうなることは決してないだろうと言っていました。
代わりに行くの
はあなたが今説明したことです。私
は人々が
私の執筆と私が作るビデオを楽しむ位置に行きたい
と思っています。これは
私がこの通常の仕事に加えて行う別のことの一種です。 私は
再びそうしました、それは私が持っていたそれらの2種類の
考え方のようでした
、しかしそれから私はまた一種のええ
と私はYouTubeからたくさんのお金を稼いだことはありません
それはいつも私がしているパトレオンシリーズから離れていました
そのような方法でそれを設定しようとしました
tiは
それで生計を立てることができますが、ええと、
私たちは今、
私たちがこれをフルタイムでやっている時点にいる
ので、おそらくこの時点
で、あなた
が興味を持っていると思う人々についてもっと話すことができます
彼らのフルタイム
の収入源または彼らの
仕事を
けいれんさせることで、あなたが彼らにとって最良の選択肢になると思うもの
は、私がこれを実現しようとしている考え方の聴衆の中に何人かの人々がいることを知っているからです
だから私はこの特定のことで成功する方法についてできるだけ多くの情報が欲しい
ので、これは
あなたに
これを
しないでくださいこれを買うのにお金を無駄にしないと言う機会を与えたいときですこれを
買う
シンプルに始め
て、成長するにつれてストリームをアップグレードする必要があると思うので、それは私がやったことであり
、新しいカメラを購入したように
うまくいき
ました。 去年はええ
覚えています
あなたがキャリアに5人いるとき
、ロジクールc920カメラ
良いカメラは青いイエティ
マイクから始めます良いマイクはこれらの2つのことから始めるの
は素晴らしいです
ゲームプレイを記録するためにelgatohd60を入手してください
合計で最大400500ドルのようになります
これらは良いかもしれませんこれら
は最初に良いことです
ええと私は今2つのPCのセットアップを持っています1つのPCが
私のゲームをストリーミングしたらもう1つのPC
はそれをキャプチャ
してインターネット
にアップロードします 始めに、
あなたはハードウェアの質問の
ようなものですか、それともハードウェアのストリーミングのようなものですか？
しかし
、私が入りたい他のことの1つは
、ジムに頻繁に行き、ありがとうございます。
ああ最近ですが、ええと、
潜在的に多くの人がいると思い
ます。あなたが
これを非常に意識しているかどうかは
わかりませんが、これを作りたいと思っている人はたくさんいると思います。 多分
これはこの特定の領域の私の
ええと狭いビューです
が 私がゲームを始めたとき、
私はゲームだけをしていて
、運動するつもりはないよう
でした。それは時間の無駄
です。あなたは食事や精神のようなことを非常に意識していますか？
健康
とジムに行って
アクティブな
ままでいるのが
好きで、あなたが寝るときのような毎日のスケジュールのように保つのが好きですそして
私がこれをフルタイムでやっているのを見つけ
たのはあなたが
あなた自身であるとき 上司それは簡単に緩むことができ
ますそしてそれから何が起こるか
あなたはあなたが
予期
していなかった何かが浮かび上がりますそして
それはあなたのキャリアに大きなへこみを作ることになります
私はyoutube
で研ぎ澄ましていて、apuでフルタイムの仕事をしてい
て、基本的には一日中机に座って
運動せずに働いていました。それから家に帰り
、夜になる
までビデオのスクリプトを書いたり、ビデオを書いたりしました。
寝
て、1年半くらいやってから
これは私が
あなたが英語と呼んでいるものを忘れてしまったものを手に入れました
それ
はあなたの背中の椎間板ヘルニアです
そして
、ええと、それは
本当に回復することはありませんでした、そして
基本的に私は今たくさんの背中の痛みを
持っています、そして私が自分自身の
世話をしていたなら私が再び元の質問に戻るならば私は簡単に避けることができ
たでしょう
あなたは
、あなたが考える必要のある変数のようなものだとは思わなかったことを学びました
が、今で
は、私の人生の残りの部分のバランスをとるためにこれをやらなければならないので、常にそれらを行っています
安定するために
は、そうだと思います。これは、私が思うすべての人のようになります。これは
、バランスの取れたメンタルヘルス
が非常に重要であることを見つけるなど、人生におけるすべての人の仕事の
一部のようなものです。 人々wh  o毎日毎日ストリーミングする
それは私の心を吹き飛ばし
ますええと5年間私はいつも
土曜日と日曜日を休みましたそれは
普通の仕事のようですええ
そしてそれは特にインターネット上でとても巨大
ですそして私はそれが作ることができる
か 誰かを壊すような人を聞いた
ことがありますが、2
週間の休みを取る
ので、男から回復するのは難しいかもしれ
ません。
まさにこれが
私が
行っているポイントです。あなたは最初にあなたが毎日粉砕していると言ったので、あなたは
休日を取り始めることを開始することを決定しまし
たか？
それから私は大丈夫だった
と思います
ここでブレーキをかける
時が来たと思いますええええええええあなたが
コンテンツを作るのが初めてで数字
が上がるのを見るとき
燃え尽き症候群はあなたがevを持っている巨大なものです
燃え尽きた
コンテンツのドゲンがうまく作成さ
れている
ので、私よりもバランスが良いようです確かに
そうです私の状況では、
最初に作業する時間がほとんど
ないので、すぐに問題になることはありません。
やめたので
ごめんなさいシリはちょうど
私の双子の娘
が生まれた
ようにapuで仕事を辞めたとたんにキックインしましたそして私は基本的
にこの
時点で専業主夫のようです
毎日youtube、
patreon、yahooで
仕事をし
ていて、収入を得るために私がすることは非常に限られているので、いわばくそったれ
の仕事をする代わりに、リラックスする機会があるような状況になったことはありません。
あなたは
それがただの人生である必要がありますが、ええと、
私があなたと同じくらい多くの時間
を持っていれば、これは確かに
私が取り組む
必要があるものになると思います
自分の頭に入るようなものy あなたの周りに十分な気晴らしがないので
、あなたを
正確に正確に遠ざけることができますええええええと
私が一人
で住んでいるならそれは大丈夫のようです私は一人で住んで
います
もし私がしたかったら、次の3か月間は何もできませんでし
た。
はい、おそらく夢中になります。そうすれ
ば、これを自分でやる気を起こさせるようなものを見つける必要があります。
巨大なええと、毎日
同じゲームをプレイ
して
いるTwitchの人々は、フォートナイトストリーマーの
ようにそれをどのように行うのかわかりません
。
私は大丈夫のようです新しいゲームは
私たち全員にとって新しい経験
です 物事を混ぜ合わせるの
は私にとって非常に重要です
ゲームで燃え尽きた私はあなたが今2週間のように
やろうとしているirlストリーミングをするためのこのええとオプションを持ってい
ます
そしてまたそのような
絵やもののように
ええと、ええと、
ええ、それ
はあなた自身のええとスケジュールを正しくするかどうかは人次第
だと思いますええええ、これはストリーミングを超えていると思います
私が言いたいポイントの1つは、
ストリーミングを始めたいと思っている多くの人が、
けいれんやyoutubeをやりたいと思っ
ていることです。
あなたはそれをしなければならなかったので、私はそれをしなければならなかったので、
後知恵2020を推測
しますが、それはあなた自身にとって将来的に物事を難しくするだけなので、過労を傷つけない
でください。
巨大なespe 最近、
けいれんのような
悪いことが起こっ
たのですが、けいれんから時間を取っ
てインターネットから時間を取って接続することで、
多くのことを回避できると思います。
私は彼らのように私たち
もそれを持ち出すことはないでしょう
が、あなたが何について話して
いるのかわからないようなものがあります
あなたを愛している人も非常に重要
であり、自分自身のために時間を割いて
、私はある種の燃え尽き症候群になっているときに気付くのが上手になり
ました。
この給料やメンタルヘルスのほうが重要なのは、
必要なときに休みを取っても大丈夫な
ことです。必要だと感じたら、みんながそうすべきだと思います。
非常に成熟したアドバイスを休んでください。 特に難しいと思う
成長を見始めている人
たちええ、あなたが見て
いる人たちがこのようになっているのを見るのは本当に難しいかもしれませ
んが、あなたは
ちょっと疲れてい
て、少し燃え尽きていますが、それはただ
式を続けています 災害のために
ええ、
あなたは休憩を取ら
なければなりませんあなたは休憩を取らなければなりませんあなたがそうする必要がない限りあなたは休憩を取らなければなりませんしかし私は
それらの人々が存在すると確信
し
ています 大丈夫ですが、
最近私は大丈夫のような考え方になっ
ていると思います私は長い間これをやってい
ます私はライブであるため、コンテンツの作成方法に関してtwitchとyoutubeは少し違うと思います
話を
やめたら7時間か8時間話をやめられない
人が
去るとYouTube
は1時間か2時間くらいのレコードが好きだと
思う なぜならあなたは
常に実際に7時間
そうしなければならないからです h少し
けいれんをしましたが、これもまた、けいれんを始め
たいと思っている視聴者向けです。私はYouTubeについて
何も知らないので、YouTuberがけいれんをしているような経験
はどうでしたか。
けいれん
をうまくやっ
たことはダイナミックですYouTubeとは
まったく異なり
ますええ私のチャンネルで何度も言ったことの1つであり、
このようなスクリプト化されていないビデオでは
、
私が成功できる唯一の方法のようなものです ユーチューブ
で私が書くことを通して私の考えを整理する時間があれば、私は
これを今見ているすべての人がここにいる
のでこれを見ていないように多くの人々が見るのに十分にこれを面白くするのに十分賢くないように
ドーガンの即席の
コンテンツを見るには、彼らがここにいるのは、私がけいれんに行ったときに持っている小さな脳力を活用するのが好きな
ときに私が書いたジョークを見たからです。
すべてのライブ
ええr 私はこのようなおっさんの
ようでした私は私が機知に富んだ
人ではないように私は時間があればしか機知に富むことができません
それの要素
がありました
トゥイッチで日本のクラスのように日本語を教えるように考えたように、多く
の人がそれに興味を持っている
と思います。それは
、多くの冗談のように言う
必要はありませんが、
知識やルールなどが好きですが、
時間がありませんでしたが
、ツイッチについて私が見つけたものの1つは、これ
についてあなたの考えを聞きたいと思うでしょう。私
は
確かにビデオゲームを芸術の一形態として見ているということです。
そして、私がツイッチでゲームをしているとき
は、最近ファイナルファンタジー
7リメイク
やオリジナルのファイナルファンタジー7をプレイしたように、あなたが今説明したことを心配する必要はありません。 これまでで
一番好きなゲームで、これは唯一のゲームの
1つです。
私が今までプレイした2つのビデオゲームは、音楽のよう
に私の人生に大きなプラスの影響を与えたと思いました。私は
まだピアノでたくさんの曲を演奏することを学んだ音楽が大好きです。
私が
そのゲームをストリーミングしていたとき、私は
大丈夫のようでした私はこれについて話したくありません私は
これを吸収する
ことによって私ができる限り多くを
手に入れたいのです あなたは
慣れ
なければならない私はもう実際にゲームをプレイしているとは思わ
ない私はちょうど私がちょうど私と同じようにそれらを粉砕するの
が好きです
まるで観客が
それを吸収するように、
カメラの電源を切り
、カットシーンを再生させます。
私が賢いお尻でない限り、何も言わない
ようにして
います。ちょっと冗談を言うのが好きです。
私が見ている間、私はほとんど
ちょうど
そしてそれは私がそれを楽しむ方法でもありますええ
と最終的なfのように antasy remakeええ
、それはすごかったので、ずっとおかしくなりました。
ええ、
その全体が1時間半のように最後のように終わりました。
ファイナルファンタジー7を初めてプレイしたので
、1、2年前のようにストリーム
でそれを吸収しまし
た。 ずっと話していたのに確かに影響を受けました
が、面白いですね。
最後に覚えているので
、人生でこれまでにプレイした中で最高のゲームの1つだった
ので、そう感じました。 とても良いmm-うーん、
それはあなたが一生覚えている素晴らしい映画のように見ているようなものでしたええええそれは
素晴らしいええ
それで私はまだ芸術を鑑賞することができます
私がそれを吸収できるようにカットシーン
大丈夫ええinteresti  ngええ、私は推測し、
いくつかのゲームは確かに他のゲームよりもストリーミングが簡単
ですええ、私は個人的には、ゲームからできるだけ多くのことを引き出し
ながら、観客を楽しませ続けるのは難しいと思います
しかし、私は人
によって少し違う
と思いますええと、私が知っ
ているように、人対ゲームは本当に彼がogストリーマーである
ようなものだと思いますそして私は彼が1年
か2年前のようにダークソウルのようにツイートしたことを覚えています3 あなたが
私たちのお気に入りのダークソウルストリーマーである
ように、人々は
あなたがダークソウル3をストリーミングするのを待つことができないようなものでした
、そして彼は彼が男のようだとツイートしました
自分でプレイするのはまさにそうそうそうそう
だし誰もが
ノーのようだったけど彼はこれは私にとって大きな意味があるようなものだ
し私は
これ
を放送だけでなく初めて体験したい
ええそうそうそれはまさに
何かt オフラインで再生すると言われ
ますええええあなたが言ったように
それを吸収しますええ私が
やらなければならなかったことはええと私がやらなければならなかったこと
はumii
が4時間か5時間のように最初のようにストリーミングさ
れました -彼女がやってきた法律彼女はその時点で
たくさんの時間を持っていた
ので彼女はやって来て、
私がやっていたyoutubeのものに加えてそれをする時間
があり
ました、そして私たちは今ここにいるベビーシッターを持ってい
ます
が それから彼女は来るのをやめなければならなかったので、私
はけいれんをする時間がありませんでした。なぜなら、
スイッチは常に私が
その上で行う追加のことだったからです。
けいれんのスケジュールを立てる時間がなくなった
正解そうそう正解大丈夫だから
私がやったのは
ここにエアロバイクがあるのでカメラから外れている
またはそう
毎日または隔日で
私は行かないようにc レイジーあなたは
適切なエンドルフィンとそのようなものを手に入れることを知っています
が、
それは机のようなものでもありますそれは
生産性バイクのようなもののようなものです
それは実際に私が
運動していたことを忘れていました私は
ゲームをとても楽しんでいるのでそれは
素晴らしいです
ええ健康なゲーマーええええ
それは私の神です私はそのゲームをとても愛し
ていました
とにかく
、ゲームについて話したくないのですが、出てくるこれらのゲーム
のような小さなポッドキャストを作成したい場合は、
これまでに作成したすべてのゲームと同じようにプレイしたので、話をしたいと思います。
この時点で、私はそうそうそうそうそうだと思います
、そしてそれは
私がいつも面白いと思っ
て
いたものの1つです。
それは李です ke oh私は
それが
どのようなものか疑問に思ってプレイしたかったので、
たぶん私はあなたのストリームに立ち寄っ
て数分間見る
のが好きです
いつも走り回っているので、それほど
頻繁にはできませんが、
私はいつも
戻って、プレイしたいゲームをプレイすることに興味
がありましたが、一度もプレイする機会がなかっ
たので
、ええと津島関郎の幽霊を知っているようです
ネオ私はこれらすべてのゲームをプレイしたいです私
はそれらすべてについて素晴らしいことを聞いたことがありますが、
私は現在時間がないので、
おそらく将来、私の女の子が学校に行き始めたら、
私はsecurosecondoの
素晴らしい
本当に良いええを強くお勧めします ソフトウェアから
私は本当に元のテンション
ゲームに
夢中になっているのが本当に好きですええ私はあなたがそれらをかなりストリーミングしているのを見ました
ええええええええそれは
私がそのゲームを打ち負かしたかったよう
でし
た 私は実際に
プレイしたことがないので、それらをストリーミングすることをお勧めします。
なぜなら、
私が一種の古典的なキックを行った
よう
に、プレイステーション1でトゥームレイダー1のように通過し、それをストリーミング
したのです。
ええ、フランチャイズにはたくさんのゲームがあることをお勧めし
ますが、そのゲーム
までのすべてのアテンションゲームで最高のものと私がプレイした
ゲーム
は、私がプレイしたゲームであると私は理解してい
ます。 それは素晴らしい
ゲームです
。それはとても楽しいかもしれないことを確認する必要があるかもしれません。ゲームのリストに追加して
、ゲームの干ばつの間にストリーミング
します。
盲目的なことで、これは
けいれんする人へのアドバイスの
ようなものだ
と私は思いますえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
あなたはゲームの
ようです 自分自身を
楽しんで時間を楽しんで
いるので
、ゲームのブラインドプレイスルーは巨大
です。おそらく私の最高のストリームは、
人々が本物の反応を愛し、本物の反応を得るのが好きだと言っていることを大丈夫にプレイし
ているようです。
私がこの男を初めて
プレイしたとき、あなたがこれをプレイするのを見るのはとてもクールだと覚えています。
また、新しいゲームは
、常にストリーミングするのに良い新しいゲームのよう
にクールすぎます。
大きな人たち
右右右右ええと、
ブラインドプレイスルーのように私はこれを続けました私
はps2が成長していなかった
ので、去年か2年
前のように私が右うんうんを逃したすべてのps2ゲームのようでした メタルギアソリッドのような
プレイスルー
メタルギアソリッドのようなものええ、
それらのいくつか、そして2、3、4、
そしてそれは
誰もがそれを愛した爆風の男のようでした彼らは
あなたがプレイしたことがない男のようですm  etal gear私は
大佐のようでした。申し訳あり
ませんが、とても楽しかったのと同じよう
に、デビルメイクプライズシリーズ
でも
そうです。 座っ
て見て、それらを見て、私が
それらを最も愛していることは、
おそらく私の好きなことです。これは
、私が5つのファンシー10のようにプレイしたことがない、これらの最愛のゲームシリーズのようなものです。
私はずっとそれを愛してい
ました
ええそれは私が実際に
本当に良いアドバイスだと
思います 新しいゲームと
あなたが言ったようなビッグボーイのような人々と競争します
ええ私は私が持っているような
510ドルのインディーゲームの
ように私が言ったように私が言ったような奇妙なインディーゲームのために蒸気を洗うようなニッチなものを見つけよ
うとします それへのいくつかの良い話と
私がloのように遊ぶのは楽しいです それが起こったとき、
ホラーゲームは本当に本当に良い
ですホラーゲームストリームを行うときはいつでも
人々はそれを愛して
いますが、私は
この時点でこれまでに作られ
たすべてのホラーゲームをプレイ
しました あなたのニッチな
インディーゲームや
、スピードランニングが好きならかなりニッチなゲームが続く
ゲーム人気のあるゲームをスピードランニングするのは楽しいでしょうスーパー
マリオ64は本当に古典的なものです
ええ私は飛び込むことをお勧めするかどうかわかりません
ビッグアアのタイトルは、ビッグボーイが
プレイ
していて、
視聴者数で見るランクをひねります。視聴
者が1,000人を超える15人がいる
場合は
、一番下まで押しつぶして、実際にスクロールする必要があります。
あなたが大丈夫だと思うので、これ
は私がちょっと入りたかったことの1つです、
そして実際に
あなたがこれをした経験があるかどうかはわかりません。
e最初はそのような爆発的な
成長を遂げました
が、私は
多くの人を知っているように、特に
けいれんしたい人のための成長と露出の方法についてあなたに一種の方法を尋ねたいと思い
ました。 聴衆とそれから
彼らの聴衆を
右にけいれんさせる
ように私はそれがすべて幸運な男
だと感じます私は完全に正直です私はあなたが非常に幸運でなければならないと思います
ええと、それを行うための良い方法ですが、
露出を得るためだけに人々と偽の友達を作ること
は私には良い考えのようには思え
ませんええ私はそのええとたくさんの経験を
しました
ユーチューブとツイッターで作った
ええそれは難しいですええ
あなたを使っている人と友達の間に微妙な境界線があり
ますええ私はそのようなものから離れようとしているのか分かりません
が私が作った友達のように 私のように ディは
私の仲間の結婚式に行きました
あなたは私がけいれんで友達を作ったように
ええと、私たちはお互いをホストしたいと思っています
これは早い段階でのようで
、私たちは自然に友達になり
ました
彼らは私
が好きだったもののために
ええと、ストリーミングしている他のけいれんの友達を得るの
は良いことだと思います
あなたは私に叫び声をあげて
くださいあなたが人々とコラボレーションするのが好きなとき
にインターネット上を歩くのは本当に奇妙なライン
です 物事と私たち二人とも
、あなたが最初に沖波に引っ越したときのあなたのビデオを見たのを覚えています。
私はこの男がとても面白いようでした。私は
彼をフォローしなければ
なりません。
そうそうあなたd アパートツアーのid
と私
はあなたがすでにジョーイまたはジョーイのようなものに会ったことがあったと思います
私はビデオのように思う
か、おそらくレイチェルとジューンはビデオが好きだっ
た
ので、私はあなたについて何も知らなかったのにそれは私のフィードに現れました
この時点で、あなたは
あなたが
その素晴らしい場所にいるよう
でした。それは大丈夫のようです。最終的に英語の教えはもうありませ
ん。私はこれをフルタイムでやっています。
あなたはアパートを通り抜けるようなものでした。
これはトイレです。これ
はバルコニーです。
私はこのエネルギーのようでした。
この男は
それを放つようなもの
です。 私の
あなたへの露出は
基本的にとても大丈夫
でしたそして私はあなたのストリームに寄付したことを
覚えていますあなたがこれを覚えているかどうか
はわかりませ
ん あなたはありがとうのようで、それから
ちょっとしたラのようでした あなたが私をフォローして
いたので、あなたはまた行くよう
でした、そして私はあなたが誰であるかを知らなかった
のであなたが私をフォローしていることを
知りませんでした。
彼はおそらく幸せだろうと寄付してください
私はとても幸せな男でした
ええ
私はあなたのビデオの1つを見つける前に
多分1、2ヶ月くらいだと思います ニホンゴジョークはそれ
についての何かだった
そうだねそうだと思うそして私は
これがとても面白いようだったああ私の神私は
この男を愛している
6月にレイチェルに会ったことがない
ので、彼らは私が存在することを知らなかったのですが、彼ら
は私のものがとても好きなので、私はあなたをフォローし始めたと思います。 よく、私は
ああのようです私は
8年のようにあなたを知っていたような大ファンです
日本に引っ越す直前のような
もので、彼らの作品をいくつか見てい
ました。私は、ピーチメルキーを通してジョーイに自然に会いました。
そうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそうそう
この種のこと
は、私が強調したい良い点だと思い
ます。これは、ネットワーキングのような点であなたが今述べたものと似ています。
つまり
、成長のために人々を使おうとすると
、 そもそも関係が
あり、
もしあなた
がフルタイムの
ユーチューブやけいれんなどになる可能性があり、あなたよりもはるかに大きくて
も人々が有機的にあなたをフォローするので
あれば
、日本では特に重要です
これを見ている人は
、日本に引っ越したり、日本で働いたりすることに興味があるのではないでしょう
か。
私が言いたいの
は、日本のクリエイターのようなコミュニティは、それがレイズだということです。  r
小さく
て接続されているので
、コンテンツに集中して、
それを可能な限り最高のものにすることをお勧めします。そうすれば、
人々はそれを認識し
、直接
友達にお願いするのではなく、友達を作る方法になります。
あなたの
コンテンツは十分に優れてい
て面白いです
これらの接続は自然に作られ
ます私はそうそう彼らはあなたの種類を見つけると思いますので
あなたがあなたのコンテンツを
できるだけ良くして
いることを確認し
てください 良い
と人々はそれを見て
自然に
形成されますそうそうそうそうそう
それは
一種の常識のようなものなので私の側で言うのは愚かなことだったかもしれません
がそれは
あなたが始めたときに再びそれはそれ
を考えるのは簡単です
私は決してそれを作ることはないだろう私はただ
これが必要
だあなたが知っているこの1つの恩恵が必要だ
彼
はエチケットの権利
が好きで、ゼロは世界最大の大乱闘スマッシュブラザーズプレーヤーのようなものだと覚えています。
彼の名前はゼロで、
彼はけいれんでストリーミングし
ていました。
私のストリームと私はそこに私のリンクを入れて、
すぐに禁止されたように私は私が
やっ
たことのようでしたが、明らかにそれは私が誰もいないようにあなたが今までにできた中で最悪のことのようであり、
私は
まあまあ
のようでした それから私と私は実際にゼロに会うのが好き
です
私が実際に誰かになったとき私は
2、3年後に彼に会いましたえ
えと
ちょうど彼がけいれんの何かで私の助けを必要
としていたので
私に連絡して、
クリス・
レトロのようになりましょう。ここで何かできるのですが、
私はあなたのチャットにタイプするのが好きで
、
3年前のようにこれをやったので禁止されました。
あなたがそれを言ったのはおかしいです
eiは実際にまったく同じことをしました
ええと、私が話したいの
は、
あなたが知っていることです。
ジョーイにも話しかけているのですが、
彼女はジョージョーイと付き合っています。アキは去年私の
アパートに
来て、タコヤキを作り
ました。オキナワを訪れたビデオを見たのを覚えて
います。 いい人たちええでもiii
は
同じことをしました彼女がこれを知っているかどうかさえわかり
ませんがええと
私は今ツイッターで彼女と話しているので私は
あなたが日本の生活と同じように知っていることをかなり定期的に知りません
しかし、私
が千人のチャンネル登録者
を持っていた当時、彼女は
ええとアニメの日本のレッスンのようなビデオを作った、または
それが一般的なアニメ用語のようなものだったので、それは
本当に面白いこの素晴らしいビデオのようでした、そして私は
そのビデオにコメントしました そして私は
何かを言った あなたの線に沿って
あなたが言ったことのように知っていますああこれは素晴らしいですえ
えと楽しいビデオ
ええと私はまたええとあなたが
日本での生活
やコメディーの日本のレッスンのようなものについての
youtubeyoutubeビデオを知っているようにします
ええと、みんなか何かをチェックしてください。
彼女
がこれを知っているかどうか、または彼女
がそれを見たことがあるかどうかさえわかりません。ええ、あなたはその
コメントを見つけて、
どこかでそれを
強調する必要があります。 ジョーイやクリスブロードのような
みんなと一緒にこの日のyoutuberリトリートに行きました
そして
私が以前に話したそのアンドリューの男私はこれとpdrがあったことを覚えてい
ますあなたがpdrを知っているかどうかはわかりません 彼に会ったことがあるなら、
別のクールな男、彼は
もっとYouTubeの日本側に
いますが、とにかく、その時点で毎週ビデオを作ろうとしていた
この1つのポイントが
あり、私のチャンネルは非常に小さかったことを覚えています
すべてのチャンネルと比較して
しかし、この時点で私はまた
、好意を求めるのが好きではないことを意識しようとしていました
、またはそれが彼らが慣れていることを知っていた
ので、私はこれらの人の誰も
おそらくこれを覚えていないことを覚え
てい
ます ええと、その週のビデオを作りたいと決心した1つのポイント
でした。その
ため、カメラ
を置いて、まるで何かについて話しているようでした。
クリスが親切に言ったことを覚えています。
私にとって皮肉なことに、
あなたはその
カメラをええと
、ビデオでこれらの他の人気のある人々を持っていることによってビューを取得することを知っているように
、私は皮肉なことに彼によく反応
しました。 今週のビデオ
あなたは皮肉なビットが明らかにそうそうだということを知っていますが、
私がそれを言ったとたんに私はああ
私の神の
ようでした r 今年のエストは
ここにあり
ます残りの旅行はそうです私は
あなたが知っているようでし
たええええでも私はあなたが元気だと思い
ます ええ、
それについては心配しないでください
ええええええそれ
は私がもう心配することではありませんが、それ
はあなたが始めたときに元のポイントに戻っているようなもののようなものですそれは
簡単だと思うのは簡単です
その罠に陥る
のはそういうことです。そういう罠に陥るのは簡単です
が、それ
は私たちの経験から学ぶ方法ではありません。
あなたはあなたを
知っています、そして私はジョーイをよく知っていますジョーイ
は私がYouTubeでそれほど大きくないような多くの加入者
を持っています
私はジョーイに会いました私は彼が誰であるか知りませんでした
hそれが最高だ
それが最高だった最高の方法だそして
後で私は
ああ何がすごいのかと思ったので私は自分自身に言った
私は
私たちの友情のほんの一部でさえも甘やかしたくありません
そして彼は
ちょうど私の友人であるように私はそれがあなたが知っているべきである方法
だと思い
ます
私たちがすでに話し合った冗長な何かです
が、
もう一度
あなたができる最高のコンテンツを作ることに集中してくださいそれが
私が作りたい基本的なポイントで
あり、
人々はそれが何であるかを認識し、
ええ、絶対に本物のええ人々になろうとします
ええ、
あなたが簡単に越えてしまうかもしれない社会的なええと境界のようにあなたが
知っている
こと
を理解してください 私は自分のコンテンツを作って、ただtに集中しようとしています
たぶん、ジェイクとベイクのように聞いたことはないと思います。ジェイク
とベイクを知っています。
ソーシャルメディアで彼を見た
ことがありますが、彼に会ったり話したりしたことはありません。
バディと彼は
特にここ2、3年のように東京に住んでいたとき、彼は
けいれんを爆発させるのが
好きでした
そして、私たち全員が東京にいるように、私たちは
両方ともirlストリーマーのようです
ええ私
はツイッターでそれを見て
大丈夫のようなものを覚えているので、
実際
には外国人のユーチューブやツイッチストリーマーのような2つの大きな種類が
日本にあります それと種類を知らなかったので
、彼は
あなたが言った
ように彼が突然爆発しているように見えたの
に気づきまし
た 私たちのああはい何の経験とmについての接線のように
私が取り戻したいことの1つは、
あなた
が日本に住んでいるほとんどの外国人が沖縄に
住んでいるという
ことです。 で東京か他のえ
えと、主に東京
よこはま大阪大都市
あなたが最近引っ越してきた大都市
沖縄のええと、私はちょっと
あなたにちょっと聞い
てみたいと思いました。
このスポンサーシップのようになりました。これで、すべての
準備が
整いました。多くの
外国人が気付いて
いないことの1つは、
バーンアウトなどの観点から先に話した
ことです。 あの
東京
オンラインでやろうとしている人にはお勧めしませ
ん。それは特に燃え尽き症候群のせいで、
今起こっていることを
コロナのよう
なもので見ることができます。 たくさんのメリット
がある静かな田園地帯
にいるので、それほど
心配する必要はありません。そうそう、私はパンツを怒らせようとしているので、少し気が狂います。 おしっこします
ええ
大丈夫申し訳ありませんが、
東京での生活は先に進みますええと東京とコンテンツを
作成し
ますええええと
あなたがそこにとどまることに決めた理由とちょうど
一般的な
考えええええと東京の男
私はirlストリーミングをしているときに本当に好きなので
、東京の外のようにカメラを持って歩き回るの
はとても素晴らしい場所です。
東京の無限のコンテンツのように終わる
ことは決してないので、それがあなたのコンテンツが進んでいるのであれば
最近、引っ越す前に東京に戻ることを考えていたのですが
、このirlストリームに戻ると、
東京のようなものは終わりがない
ような人のところにあるので
、電車に乗ることができます。
毎日違う場所
うん、コンテンツは
裏側で終わることはあり
ません。刑務所ではなく、コンクリートのジャングルのように住むことになりますが
、エリアに少し機械的なもの
があるようですが、無限のコンテンツも
あります。
私は1年のように大丈夫だと思います私は
東京で毎日6ヶ月のirlストリーミングが好きでした
そしてそれの終わり近くにそれ
は少し繰り返し始めたと思います私は大丈夫のようです
強いゼロ
と日本人が
酔っ払ってキャンパスの渋谷
で最初はとても楽しかったですそれは
文字通り毎回同じように出会う
ようなものです
つい最近、ここで再びirlの仕事を始めまし
た。とても楽しかったですが、
引っ越してきた場所に引っ越してくれてありがとう。
今住んでいる男
は沖縄の西原にいます。
t 彼の最も近い軍事基地ああ
面白いええ
と、ここからかなり遠いところにあるのは、基地
を避けるという意識的な決定だったということです
ええええええ私はaiに住んでいなかったので
文字通りアメリカの村と呼ばれる場所の隣に住んでいました
そうそうそうそう私はその場所を知っています
ええチャトンでそうですそれは軍事基地のすぐ隣にいるようなものです
ええと私は外に出てどこにでも外国人がい
ますそしてそれ
はいいです
ええと、
あなたが知っている海兵隊はいつも酔っ払った海兵隊員を知っている
ので、それは私が日本に引っ越した理由ではない
ので、私は日本に戻らなきゃいけないので、ここ沖縄の田舎に行ってみましょう
今、
私は再び田舎の日本にいるように戻ってきました。これ
はおそらく私のお気に入りの場所の1つ
です。
ええ、私は
間違いなくそこにいます
窮屈さや狂気が少ないだけでなく
、生活費がはるかに低く、
コンテンツ作成
コンテンツ作成を
行ってインターネットでお金を稼いでいる
ときは、自動的に節約できるという利点がたくさんあります。
田舎に住んでいるだけでたくさんのお金がかかる
ので、もしあなたが退屈していなければ、
それは経済的な
決定です
ええ、ここでの私の家賃は600
ドルのようなものかもしれません。
部屋
ええ、私の寝室は東京のあそこにあり
ます
1315かもしれませ
んええ、私がここbeppuに持って
いる私のコンドミニアムは、東京の少なくとも2倍の費用のようだったでしょうが
、ここではそれは私ができないようです
詳細に入るが、
それは望ましい場所であり
、東京にいなかったのでそれを買う余裕
がありましたええ、私は先月ここに
引っ越したばかりだったので、正直に引っ越しを探し
てい
ました。 私がここに来ただけの新しいエリア
1か月間
、東京のアパートも見ていたのですが
、値段はあの人に
戻りたいかどうかわかりません。
おもしろいですね。それはいいセグエかもしれません。
最後
に聞いてみ
たのは
、20分か15分くらいで行かなく
てはいけないので、5分くらいでできるかもしれませ
んが、あと5分で
話せます
私
たちは立ち止まった後ですが、確か
に私の数字を見るのはどういうことかわかりません
私の収入の数字や
YouTubeをやっていて、私がやっていることをやっています
が
、あなたはあなたが心配している立場にい
ます
もしあなた
がチャンスをつかんで
新しいことを知っ
ていて、Twitch
がフルタイムの仕事であることにどれほど快適であるかと同じように、あなたは将来について心配して
いますか？
マーチとそのようなものええと、
私はtwの収入にかなり満足しています
確かに
私は最近新しいスポンサーを持って
います、そして彼らは
あなたがここで見るこれらの絵が好きなようにたくさん助けてくれ
ます私たちはいくつかの絵の流れをしました
そしてあなたは視聴者が大丈夫だったことを知ってい
ます いつものようにリスクを冒すのと
同じように
私はこのゲームをプレイするのと同じように
絵のストリームをやりますええと私はirl
ストリームに行き
ます
バラエティ放送局
私はいくつかの奇妙なゲームをプレイして
いますええあなたがスタートレックを見ていたのは
それほど昔
のことではありませんええそれは本当に本当に楽しかった
です
もう仕事はありません
よね、私たちはいつも
お金を節約することを意識してきました
これは私が
明らかにお父さんなのでもっと意識
していることです
m非常に質素な私はその言葉だと思います
はいああ
そうそう私の悪い何人かの人々l 私
を安い嫌いな人と呼ぶの
が好きですが、
それを説明する別の方法である質素
な言葉が好き
です
えええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ それから
私は私の手段の範囲内でかなり単純に生きています私は
あまり派手なものを持っていません
私は車を所有していません私は走り回るモップを所有して
います
そしてそれは4ドルでいっぱいになるので
理論的にはとても興味深いです
数年のように良いと思います
私はそうではないのでそれは良いことだと思い
ます私は本当に何も買うのが好きで
はありません
新進気鋭のコンテンツクリエーターのために
あなたのお金を節約すること
は確かに
あなたが今のようにあなたがそうすることができるのと同じ
くらいあなた
のお金を節約する お金のことお金の
ようなものがスポンサーの
お金に入るc けいれん潜水艦を介してのいくつ
かのライブストリーミングは
、
人々があなたがお金を使っているの
を見て、あなたが夕食を食べているように見えるので、収入に本当に
良いです 私の
irlストリームはゲームよりも高価ですが、irlストリームは
実際にはいつも外出し
てお金を使うのが好きな
ので、ゲームの20はここに座って、
5日間まっすぐにプレイ
できます。
大丈夫だと思いますええと、これはおそらく
最後に物事を終わらせるのにかなり良い場所です。私は1分か2分わからないので、私
たちが再び人々に行く前にあなたが言及し
たいことが他にありますか？ けいれんストリーマーになるために、
または彼ら
はコンテンツ作成をするために日本に来たいと思っています
これについては長い間話しましたので
私は繰り返したくないですええ
あなたが来るつもりなら私は思います
ここでコンテンツの作成を行う必要があります
dおそらく、あなたはおそらく同時に英語の仕事をしていることを理解するために、
最初は大丈夫
です。
それは私が知っていたことです。
あなたはあなたの冒険に行きますあなたの冒険に
行きそしてあなた
が日本で英語を教えたいならそれは
完全にクールですそして
あなたがここに住んでいることを通して自然に開く道があるかもしれませんそれは
私がけいれんになるとは思っていなかったようです
私が日本に引っ越したとき知っているストリーマーですが、
英語を教えたり、
他のことを試したりすることで自然に
これが私の人生になり
ました。 日本に引っ越して
、彼らはそれを嫌い、私は
あなたが理解しなければならないことを強調しなければなりませんええと私は
この
アニメが本物では
ないと言うのが
嫌い
です おそらく
ここに来たら、友達を作るの
も大変です。
神川に引っ越したとき
は、人生で最悪の時期だったと思います。日本に初めて来たときは、
とても寂しかったです。
私はまだ
神川にい
て、人生で最高の年だったので
、日本に引っ越してすぐに幸せになるだけで
なく、夢が叶うように
頑張らなければなりません。 普段よりもたくさん
出て行かなくて
はいけないのですが、
いいことになるといいの
ですが、
いつも緊張しているので気をつけ
てください。 日本にとっては、リスクがたくさんある
ことを本当に理解してもらいたいのですが
、そうですね、私がいつもアドバイスしているの
は、日本は
あなたの夢の仕事をするのに最適な場所ですが、その
仕事をするのは悪い場所です。
特にtokyのような場所では嫌いです o
労働文化が
かなり強烈で、特に
東京のような場所では
、日本の一般的な生活のように食べ物
が素晴らしいと
言ってください。けいれんやユーチューブのようなことができれば、すべてがモダンでとても安全です。
私はそれを愛している
男私は絶対にそれを愛している
私はそれを愛しているが誰もが私たちの生活を持っているわけではない
ええ、それはいい
ですね。私たち
はたくさんの接線をたどり、
昔の過去の過ちのように話し合った
と思います。私たちは自分自身を繰り返したと思います。
少なくとも
数十回このビデオを繰り返しました。 この時点
ではかなり長い1時間45分
です
が、私が通常話していることとは異なる視点やアドバイス
で、このウムから何かを得ることができたと
思い
ます
。 レトロは私がこれを言っても大丈夫だと想像しますが、
私たちが両方とも話していることの1つは、
実際にポッドキャストを開始することを考えているということです。
私の
女の子は
学校に通い始めたので、それ
を見たいと思ったら、その特定のアイデア
についてのあなたのみんなの考えを教えてください
。これが楽しいと思う人が十分にいるなら、
私はこれを見るのが好きだった
ので、私はあなたたちに会いたいです
日本
で1時間デートすることを知っているより具体的なことや
、私が過去に話したことのあるさまざまなトピックについて話しますが
、日本でも成功したこの素晴らしい人とは、
それをやりたいと思っています
将来、私の女の子が学校に通い始めたら、
私たちはちょうどこの時点で時間切れになっ
ているので
、あなたがけいれんに興味があり、ゲームが好きなら、けいれんの
レトロな外人をチェックしてください
、そしてええと、あなたは
おそらくたくさん見るでしょう の詳細 将来彼に
会えるので、見てくれてありがとう。またすぐに会いましょう。